et on repart et gauthier rybinski
bonsoir gauthier secrétaire d'état
américain donc à bien dit tout
franchissement de la frontière
ukrainienne par la russie entraînant une
réaction rapide et sévère des états unis
et joba et donne également clarifié en
disant que finalement tout entrée des
troupes russes en ukraine serait une
invasion puisque hier pendant sa
conférence de presse il avait fait une
distinction entre invasion et
incursions mineurs donc qu'en est-il
gauthier est ce que ce sont de nouvelles
lignes rouges à force de dire qu'il y a
des lignes rouges à force de dire que la
tension est au plus haut on ne peut pas
utiliser si vous voulez des superlatifs
encore plus frappant
qu'est ce que ça veut dire au fond de la
part des américains ce que dit anthony
blinken une réponse rapide et sévère et
c'est là qu'est le problème au fond
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si ce n'est
pour l'instant on n'a pas entendu parler
d'actions militaires ce dont on entend
parler c'est des sanctions économiques
qui nous dit-on frapperait très fort le
portefeuille de moscou et notamment le
portefeuille personnel de vladimir
poutine ce qui serait une nouveauté mais
quand vous regardez l'histoire de ces
sanctions et notamment depuis 2000 14
depuis de même avant depuis la géorgie
la crimée etc ça n'a pas empêché les
russes de continuer ça n'a pas empêché
même si on veut pas parler de chose
militaire ça n'a pas empêché les
attaques massives les cyber attaques
massives de hackers russes ça n'a pas
empêché non plus j'allais dire le
les tentatives ou même parfois
malheureusement les assassinats réussie
de la part de moscou vis-à-vis
d'opposants donc même des chaises en ont
conscience
oui et c'est mais je crois que si vous
voulez ses écarts de langage où l'on dit
parfois
finalement c'est pas très grave ce qui
est dangereux d'ailleurs parce que ça
peut inciter les russes à agir et puis
parfois comme on l'entend aujourd'hui si
les choses sont très graves il y a une
position qui paradoxalement peut être
intéressante c'est celle qui confirme
que les choses sont graves parce que ça
donne à moscou la certitude ou
l'impression c'est selon que les
occidentaux prennent au sérieux la
menace
et ça vous ne peut pas comprendre cette
subtilité psychologique
si on ne sait pas ou si on ignore que
j'allais dire le drame de la russie
c'est d'avoir été d'ailleurs sergueï
lavrov le dire régulièrement c'est
d'avoir été trompée et notamment dans
les rangs des années 90 ou à propos de
l'otan il était question de ne pas
l'élargir et finalement la pologne a
adhéré donc pour la russie c'est quelque
chose de capital et il faut que
l'adversaire ou le partenaire c'est
selon eux aussi prennent au sérieux la
menace quand en revanche un job hayden
la minimise il a ici aussi la mini lisez
vous savez dans une autre partie de sa
conférence de presse oui a dit bon en ce
qui concerne l'ukraine elle n'adhérera
pas tout de suite et c'est un euphémisme
à l'otan
pour le reste pour les manoeuvres de
l'otan on peut aussi en discuter est ce
que c'est ça c'est ça le mystère est ce
que c'est ça vraiment que les rues seul
on n'en sait rien on n'en sait rien
oui ils ont quitté leurs propres lignes
rouges à l'entrée dans l'otan de
l'ukraine oui mais les russes savent que
ce n'est pas admissible les russes
savent que ce n'est pas admissible ne
serait ce que pour l'otan mais aussi en
droit international chaque pays qui est
reconnue et qui est sa souveraineté est
en droit d'adhérer à l'union qui à
laquelle ils souhaitent adhérer donc on
est vraiment dans un dialogue de sourds
que va-t-il se passer demain puisque son
homologue sergueï lavrov à genève
alors blinken après avoir remonté les
muscles a dit qu'il avait vu des petites
avancées modestes dans l'immédiat
justement c'est pas de régler le fond de
la faire c'est de procéder justement à
des mesures de désescalade c'est à dire
de voir comment par exemple on peut
alléger la situation à la frontière
ukrainienne alors ça peut être
microscopiques mais ça peut être par
exemple un tout petit retrait de
quelques kilomètres des troupes russes
ça peut être ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
des mesures qui crée la confiance c'est
à dire qu'une fois qu'on a maintenant
qu'on a créé opérer certains changements
on peut penser qu'à ce moment là on peut
essayer de discuter de manière un peu
moins méfiantes parce que c'est ça quand
vous dites la tension est à son comble
c'est surtout qu'il ya une méfiance
absolument phénoménale entre les deux et
que donc à la fois montrer qu'on prend
au sérieux les russes et leur dire bon
écoutez si vous voulez discuter de foot
du fond on peut le faire mais desserrer
un petit peu l'étau et ne donnait pas
l'impression que vous allez vous jeter
comme un chien sur un os sur l'ukraine
merci beaucoup gauthier